god it's been a while i got a stick a
gross left arm and a lighter
oh yuck ah don't come by me with that
that's terrible
oh god i've forgotten i remember that
and it's good
yeah it's a little it's like when i
tried to take my vitamins this morning
and i was all
oh yeah i kind of bumped everything a
little bit
i almost birthdayed myself you just had
a birthday so you could celebrate it by
birthday
i don't want to do that
[Music]
sorry about that i just needed to ask
you a question
i think you can answer him what is this
what is this thing that bob wade and i
made because if you don't know what this
is
then we have a problem and there's a
link in the description that can educate
you
on what this is so why don't you click
on that
and you think about what this is and
i'll be back to quizzy again
ah man i've forgotten entirely how to
play i don't know anything what i'm
doing yeah what do we do
oh we were trying to actually make
progress but then we built a wall that
we haven't built
way over there yeah we do have a map
we do so we obtained a map and we've
explored a lot of it we were looking
wait what's in my
what's in my oh what's in my inventory
did we get we have scuba
gear so we can dive chainsaws scuba gear
there's a better hatchet we could have
gotten that we haven't yet
we got the climbing axe too yeah we got
the climbing axe
we have all that i medicine i have food
question mark
okay if you pull out your map and you
look over in like the left
part there's a cave that's kind of just
appearing on the map
i think that's where we were supposed to
be
m i don't think i have a map you didn't
get a map well that sucks for you then
i have the map and i am going to be our
guide
all right let me take a look at the map
again okay so if i remember correctly
the last step that we left off on
was getting a key card to get into a
science container of some sort we
already swam
through the scuba section i think so
there is definitely another cave that is
near those other caves that we
were going to that is going to be where
we need to go
next i believe the boat key card that's
what we need
we need the boat key card and i could
look this up
i could look this up but why do that
when we could just explore
oh right i built the invisible fence
that we could see through i'm gonna take
that down because it's terrible
why did i do that oh the bridge oh god
the nightmare bridge
oh i have to delete these one edit oh my
god
no see i think that's where we landed at
is that's not worth it
yeah that's not worth it oh yeah we
built the raft
oh yeah oh yeah the raft the raft was
terrible
yeah the over the ref wasn't that bad
never trying to we're trying to get the
sled
onto the raft yeah yeah yeah oh it's for
the days
those were the days indeed all right but
you guys ready to adventure
i've got one dude let's do it all right
cool
follow me hey they put like a a little
uh
pin on here so we can see where we're
going oh hell yeah
all right follow me boys i will not lead
us astray
okay trust myself more no it's fine well
i'm not gonna hey neighbors
oh hey oh hey neighbors oh hey friends
hey neighbors oh my god don't mind me
oh hey oh they took my arm off
stop get stop stop stop hey hey
i remember them dying a lot sooner from
this uh
you know changes maybe i should be using
my chainsaw not this stick
wow oh oh oh i'm going down
what was my health thing uh hang on i
got it oh oh my god that hurt
way too much uh did i take medicine
yeah that guy he hits too hard
ow take that to the knee oh oh my god he
came from behind and made such scary
noises
ow ow ow
where's my katana do i have any of these
weapons what happened to me oh i thought
you did
i'm gonna just to rinse off a little bit
here
oh yeah the blood uh there's probably a
river on the way
you guys keep going i'll get there all
right well you catch up when you you
know
in fact i think next time we'll just run
through them we won't stop to fight them
because it's kind of
maybe a better plan yeah it's kind of
apparently i lost my katana
and my map but i don't need them do i
have anything to heal with
i have meds right you have meds you
should have massive oh i got meds
yeah restoring health maybe no i'm good
we're
wealthy i remember now all right sounds
good
ah it's hard to run and look at a map at
the same time
so you guys tell me if i'm about to run
oh looks like we're running into a
village that's probably not the best
idea this is fine we'll clean it out
like we cleaned out the block party we
just didn't yeah absolutely bob you back
there
okay good i'm coming okay cool i'm out
of stamina
but i'm coming we're gonna skirt around
this village no one will be the wiser
howdy neighbors please tell me there
aren't neighbors that are looking at us
i don't see any actually maybe i no i
don't and we're clear good
good good good am i not supposed to say
hello to the people in the village
you do tell them to come to the arcade
that's a different thing never mind the
art wait
you need that's just rgta rp [ __ ]
you don't know that
i do know that yeah i think he would
know don't play bob what are you doing
later good god you have a problem
i would love to play because it's only
on on the weekends and i don't stream on
the weekends
what's that we should have it open on
every weekday should i would play a lot
if it was open every weekday
i'm a lawyer mark would join if it was
open on weekdays right mark wait why is
it
whoa is this the pit oh [ __ ] this is
still very new
it's very dark so just be aware the pit
is in front of us and
i don't know how far it is in front of
us the pit i see it it's just
down this cliff and then like another 10
feet oh hey dudes how's it going
don't go in the pit is what i'm trying
to say i can't run
what is this i don't know why can't you
run so much i see okay
you're like why am i falling into the
pit that's the club
careful uh thank you i think is this
water what is this
definitely go in there and see what
happens yeah it goes what is this
go see it's like it's a clay circle what
am i on i don't know what are you on
wait wait mark look at me you have a
mustache oh my god yeah you took your
advice yeah you have a mustache no no
you have
you you have less hair than i do oh
maybe like a forehead okay the top of
your head looks like mine your face is
balderino
it's a little rude maybe you can't grow
a facial hair you ever think about that
not my problem all right this way
this is our problem though as the
collective yeah um
i almost just marked myself what do you
mean
very large bottle of liquid almost just
went right into a thing it really
shouldn't
what do you mean but i almost juiced my
god
i where am i
hello i don't in a pond do you have
eyeballs are you okay
i'm looking at my map some of us have a
map and some of us don't the other
person is you
if you were looking at the map shouldn't
you have gotten us there faster
i am getting a sarah as fast as we can
go but you can't sprint very good so
it's your fault
now if i wasn't so stingy with my hey i
found a cave is this what we're looking
for
ooh maybe i don't think that it's
that cave i think we've been in that
cave system before
yeah we've well maybe not no we've been
there we've been in this one before
i think we have yeah so we're looking
for something there's another cave that
should be just
north and west of here should be here
what you doing
i'm looking for it it's apparently bunny
there's apparently a cave here
uh well it's probably just like a little
hole in the ground or something right
yeah so oh oh uh here here here okay
yeah
have we been here i don't think we've
been in this one this feels like the
place where wade and i were screwing
around with that dude who was waiting
outside and we were all
nope only one way to find out only one
way to find out okay well that's going
one way to find out oh my god flag
all right okay this is new because the
cave now turned into the interior and it
is unexplored
my scuba gear is
i see the canisters for the air i see
the scuba gear
my rubber rebreather is above my
backpack top left
we may not need anything we might not
need it i think there was only one
flooded section might be a
short trip for me ah cool screeching i
love that about this game screeching
all right wait swim down there and see
what's going on [ __ ] god damn it you
guys even pointed it out it's still got
me
oh is this like a cooking pot nope we
can't have that we can't have nice
things
oh i thought that was one of you making
rocks but it wasn't one of them no i was
not
i'm going in all right go in
what are these things oh it's fingies
yeah guys look thingies hey cool
oh a thigh ah
that's a muscly thigh yeah must have
been pretty real
well yeah i guess i'll go down the thing
i guess
at least we don't see anything at the
bottom of it this time it's too bad i
can't look directly down
beneath me when
oh yeah that's great man okay good
clearly you've been working
the most important future taking a
little rabbit break
yum i'm half hungry already uh-oh
i don't know if i brought food yeah i
got i got candy too there were candy
bars up there yeah
oh i got i got snacks
oh hey look at them yeah there's gray
dudes uh do you want to throw i have
dynamite i think
i have a bunch of molotovs oh yeah yeah
we can make
molotovs let me i'll attempt them with
my ass while you guys hit them look at
my butt
and hunger oh there's some i have yeah i
have a lot of molotov so
that's what i'm going to keep making i'm
going to try and hit those babies
i'm going to go up a little bit just in
case these things have a large lighting
radius
oh that'll get him i think i'm full up
on molotovs
okay oh no i pissed him off by igniting
the babies
oh i almost fell oh my god i'm gonna oh
i'm falling
oh my god i'm running give me up
[Music]
you know tyler you just went right
through me yeah yeah i climbed into your
colon and out your house
oh you're gross man why don't we have a
bow and arrow
naked can we i've mined with these guys
can we do we like mind meld with them or
something why are these not lighting oh
i'm not
lighting them on fire i might not light
mine up
oh that works much better wow that's
much better oh yeah i got him i got him
oh my god
nice nice all right wait let's do this
wait let's do this do it
wait get it come on wait get him wade
i'm gonna get you little shits
where's my weapon oh no they're not dead
they're just really crispy
all right i'm coming down guys i'm
coming down i'm coming down fast as i
can
i got mine wade you get yourself right
to the dick oh hey mark thanks for the
help bud you got it
you got them hey there's some teeth down
here if you want them
right in the dick love teeth love teeth
get your gross arm out of me sorry yeah
oh my god hey look at the fish guys
oh yeah totally do this that's a rock
wade i'm a [ __ ] idiot
good job man good job thank you i'm a
professional can you not fish fish in
this game i thought you could fish fish
you can definitely fish fish guys i
don't have a rebreather oh hey i got one
you don't need a rebreather man it's
fine
oh there's something in the darkness oh
there's something in the darkness okay
okay it's just a friendly neighborhood
wow okay
sorry if there's friendly fire oh
there's two
guys out i got hit sorry i hit you i
don't know
all right that one's down one down one
running
i'm gonna heal oh my god did it hit me
yeah oh my god
oh my god it only wants you okay hitting
hitting hitting oh hey guys how you
doing
oh i might need to rest up a bit but i'm
good i see fires in the darkness
oh hey look there's a guy coming
he excuse me i think yeah i'm gonna just
uh-huh i'm just gonna like
uh somebody get a weapon out i got a
weapon i got a lighted molotov
i mean i remember having a walk blocking
i'm tanking i'm tanking
i've got his attention i've got aggro
open his ass whoop his ass
baby oh okay did not tank did not tank
good
did tanked bad i tanked poorly i
unblocked i should have kept blocking
i'll get mark you're fighting
thank you you guys are saints i love you
welcome back don't move okay blocking oh
okay learn um oh my god they're doing
combat roles and [ __ ]
yeah they're advanced you gotta hit in
i'm gonna take a minute that's right
that will win better better better
okay it's in the midst oh oh oh
trying to block attempting blocks
blocked oh i should not have stopped
walking oh i'm going knock
okay i need an adult i literally
am dying right now blocks still take
damage apparently i'm down
you're down oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it might
just be you okay no no no
no no it's not not we're gonna get them
we're gonna get this all right
i'm here i'm healing yeah my lighter's
back up
you're in the corner your mind your mind
your mind your mind
on your left mark okay we got one of
them down
getting weighed are you dead yeah
i forgot you played it out oh that was a
fast bleed out though
oh my god yeah it says i still had time
did you press here or something my
[ __ ]
okay that one's down yeah oh god how the
hell do i find you guys
where are you back at camp uh the plane
oh you're back at the plane do you have
nothing
[ __ ] okay all right um yeah
oh yeah because the stuff is down here
right right right okay
all right i may be able to look at the
map and i may be able to see where the
plane is
see where you're tuned you got babied
the baby down [ __ ] you stop
ow oh my god they suck i'm professional
okay got me down
is there one more or is that it man that
sucked okay uh let me look at the map
see where the plane is oh i only have
the underground map god damn it
i don't think you could cycle maps well
so i can see where wade is at
oh yeah uh which way is that do we have
a compass
wait can you see us our names i see yeah
i'm heading to where you guys are but
that won't be the entrance to the cave
so i'll have to refine that
huh do we backtrack mark uh we could
yeah then we could be at the cave
entrance that probably the easiest way
or i can go and you can explore but if
you also want to come back i understand
all right wait i'm going to go to the
entrance i'll put can we we can put
landmarks down we should have uh
landmarked
oh all right i'm coming i don't remember
how to put down a landmark over there
i'm asking the mysterious gods of chat
who i respect
incredibly and admire oh you gotta craft
it
oh oh i didn't know that would make
sense
okay what was the crafting menu no
that's radio
wait why are you talking in cape that
was creepy sorry yeah i brought up my
radio okay
signals no uh what do we got what do we
got what do we got what do we got oh hi
bob
um hey mark there's like guys on fire
over there
uh it's fine oh fun i don't see a
landmark kind of thing it's okay i don't
think you need one
hey guys are you here oh hey how's it
going oh hey
maybe i do oh there we go hey yeah
there's a there's a
mark thing okay cool we'll disassemble
at that when we finish here
oh my god the bat is still there guys
okay
there is another section for a
rebreather down this way which i might
jet down real quick and see what's there
but
why is my thirst dropping so fast in
this godforsaken hellhole
i don't know probably it's a god for
second hell hole that might affect it
yeah
all right we should be near where we
were
wade's body should be right about
that's a rock here no here no
here no yes here no somewhere here
can i not drink from this lovely cave
pond don't drink
full of bodies and whatnot i don't care
thirsty
you might want to care i don't see
wade's corpse
do you see wade scorps wade's corpse
yeah wade
future wade's corpse do you see your
corpse
in the making do you see the old corpse
got it
okay good um you want me to jet down
this bottomless pit yeah wait do you
want to check it out
hell yeah uh i'll hold like a i'll hold
my liner up here so you can see okay
oh yeah we have flashlights oh wait i
have flashlight on the rebreather that's
fine wait we have a flashlight
it just goes down okay there's a it
levels out here
um a lot of rock formations uh it kind
of goes
on a bit it levels out to a surface area
there's well actually i don't even know
there's people down here
oh but there's a there is a lot of stuff
down here
oh god oh god i'm going back oh oh he's
in the water too
he's alive in the water is that possible
oh he died okay they can drown maybe if
i lead him into the water i think
actually you guys might be able to make
that swim without the rebreather
well i have one i'm cool so so wade you
might be able to make it there's some
stuff that's
so you're saying we should come check it
out yeah it looks amazing
because i literally can't see all right
wade you ready yeah
let's do this i'm gonna try to lead
another one into the water because that
was an effective strategy oh here they
come
still on me wade uh i think so it might
be ahead of you
oh yeah watch out go up go up go up go
up oh yeah he's in the water
get in the water come on drown drown oh
i got him oh my god i drowned him holy
crap
i did it these guys are stupid one of
these
wait is that something explosive in
there could that have killed me what is
that you know i wouldn't be surprised
man
i think it's a projector technology [ __ ]
it
we got gaskets here technology you get
computer parts
i don't know what we need computer parts
for i can't hold the circuit board
hey
oh arrows holy crap good arrows
[Music]
just you wait till i fill up my skull
two more three more wade water strategy
quick
oh god oh yeah there's a lot in the
water in the water in the water
come get me get your promising wedding
in the water come here
come here [ __ ] come at me i'm gonna
lead him a little more
oh
them or one of them anyway you do that
hey this my molotov if i let it warm me
up
come here come here yes yes it's in the
water drown drown
drown [ __ ]
it's all good this one's not smart we
got one drowning okay
oh that's gross that's pretty gross hey
what's up
cut it now come at
please warm me with your body yeah
burning flesh of my enemies warm my soul
yes please oh it's working no it's not
working it's working it's not working
all right i'm gonna pretend like it's
burning body warmed me up
oh i want your candy bar
that's nice oh that's nice i lost my
groceries that's
real nice that's real nice wait
something's wrong with the shape of my
hand
i think it's bloody you need to wipe
that off oh gross
all right i'm warm all right cool all
right let's see what else
good job everybody yeah well done team
we're really nice i mean i have any of
the items i need to progress but at
least i've got
this skull there's some meds over here
yeah there's one i thought that was a
headphone symbol those are drugs
i always get them confused i
often confuse headphones i've swallowed
so many pairs of airpods
guys please designers
you need to fix your [ __ ] hey guys i
found a bunch of coins over here that's
pretty cool
oh make some money oh there's babies
down here
oh there's a dude i don't i don't like
that okay this is
my favorite hitting me stop hitting me
stop hitting me oh another one out okay
i'm i'm down oh god oh god oh no
i'm joining you oh no no bob oh no it's
all up to you bob
oh no bob we love you and we believe in
you and you're the best and
uh love you love you lots
i'm getting weighed up good job
oh my god i got you up and a baby it
came at you right away
did you go back out immediately i
immediately dropped oh no god damn it
okay i'm getting mark now okay i will
eat medicine right away there we go
there we go i'm getting running away
right now i'm running away medicine mark
i have medicine there's no one here
we're fine don't run that way that way
that's a bad way
we're fine right here we're fine right
what the hell was that oh there's a
little baby over there
i got it okay okay i'm gonna break down
this barricade see what's behind here
i bet it's something good aha
oh hi oh good
hey guys i found something thank you oh
dear me yeah hey guys
lunch with megan collected oh good you
know what we could do with them
what we could have a real three-headed
expert
who wants to be our three-headed expert
i i
hey all right well that was nice and all
but not
essential to our progress in the story
so i'm assuming there must be more
around here
well i'm glad we got to meet those guys
though oh yeah they're dope they're cool
as hell
i love these guys my lucky numbers are
i'm trapped on an island who [ __ ]
cares i mean if if i were to find lucky
numbers on a
island filled with cannibals i might be
inclined to uh
play those numbers when i get back home
there's a there's a book here called
the dark haired man which i think you
all
know who that's in reference to me i
have very dark hair
i mean i have pretty dark hair i'm not
gonna say it coming down
don't stop i'm not stopping is that a
baby or is that a
lion monster what am i looking at oh my
god i can't believe i missed that
reference
wait do you know what i just thought of
something big what it's trumping around
so
two heads thick skateboard
oh i missed it too i know right
unbelievable how much you love that
reference break
and fix i think it's a dead enough to
buy a new skateboard
new skateboard that's true why is this a
dead end i don't know i've never seen
just a dead end like this
it looks like there's a way down here is
this breakable oh this is teen this is
dynamite you dynamite
oh okay oh [ __ ] oh yeah you get really
close to the rock
okay i have dynamite i don't have none
of that
okay i'll throw i'll remember to light
it this time you can't just throw an
unlit stick of dynamite how long do i
have to throw oh that's terrifying
hold it for a while see what happens oh
yeah hey
all right yay what is this
oh you found a skull i'll hit another
one uh i don't i only had the one but
there was dynamite further up though
yeah there's another
i got i got lots of things okay
remember to light it okay count to ten
ten that wasn't ten
oh my god i like how when you move into
the range of the dynamite the game is
like oh yeah your ears are ringing or
something oh yeah yeah
but only here a lot your ears ring near
the dynamite
well this looks safe oh yeah wait tell
us what's on the other side
uh more caves i'm in your head darkness
a really narrow pathway
cool cool candles
oh screaming i love screaming there's
lots of um
very goopy yeah extremely i heard this
is actually a foot treatment
oh my god this big a baby potato guy
ah okay i'm gonna molly him from
way downtown he charges just remember
this about this man
this thing this man they'll never know
we're here bam
hello we're here oh good i got him is he
dead yeah he's dead man he's dead
yeah he's super dead if someone wanted
to throw dynamite at him thinking that's
also a puzzle i'm gonna get another
molotov ooh he's charging he's driving
and turning oh my god
cutting him oh my god i'm slicing back
off back home
yay
i'm on the rocks as well i'm waiting to
bait him oh god i fell in a pit i want a
baby
hard good good molly okay i'll drop him
through it this way oh
come on slicing dice i don't like that
oh i got kicked oh my god my god mark
are you okay
i'm okay all right i let him i got him
this molly good molly i'll slice him
while he's burning
no he can't kick while he's burning i
think all right
wait wait three lighting oh is he dead
he's dead
oh i just how long do i have this
molotov how is it safe to hold this i
don't know
the whole didn't see what happens i
guess yeah i'll see what happens oh
this is for you got him
what do i get from him if i oh oh no i
got an
arm oh i sure did do i get anything
someone might be coming
oh oh i'm just gonna go ahead and do
this while i'm
turning my back to that all right
turning on it putting this on i'm gonna
go ahead and get some more molotovs
ready
yeah i should use the rusty axe to block
because it has great block
so i'm going to tank it up man all right
tank them i will tank them
i have aggro you have aggro oh god i was
looking at a story item
don't be afraid just believe don't be
afraid just believe
oh oh my god got him [ __ ] cave oh wow
he went down hard
he did oh okay story item yeah don't be
afraid just believe yeah
story item don't be afraid man just
believe
guys there's explosives here be aware
oh hell yeah
there's another story i like this boat
down here that's pretty cool
there's some really tiny like baby sized
life wraps on the wall uh-huh oh hey
dynamite
yeah oh my god so much dynamite
there must be some more kaboomables the
limestone hey did you get the story
thing over here
is this oh where did the where did the
dynamites
sit uh bottom left below this
the like sharpened stick there oh i see
i see what's going on
this is a tall ass rope guys oh hi sir
one life at a time
uh someone had a bad day here
he's still alive having a bad day or is
it over i had
past tense had a bad day you were so
close to the top man i'm sorry
[Applause]
oh yeah so sad tragedy really
put away a little effort next time billy
okay you don't need to be so
so condescending oh it's a drawing of
the ring
or something it's probably safe yeah
totally safe oh
it is a drawing of the ring or something
oh i thought we actually got a mining
helmet but i can't it's just a
ticket it's like some kind of building
or something
oh these are flares are we leaving the
cave right now
i think so actually yeah this is yeah
we're out does anybody know where the
key card is
[Music]
you